so the question is one why do women
automatically get tough custody and two
why are we putting single motherhood on
a pedestal like this is something that
men should sign up for when it is clear
that these are the issues that kid was
not well behaved and it's clear because
he's had a decade of living with a
mother that does not allow The
Stepfather to discipline him and is not
getting proper discipline at home young
boys need discipline from young men
women cannot do it the same way that men
can't that's why honestly guys I think
it's quite weird when you see female
bosses like yelling at young men it's
like such a weird dynamic to me it's a
weird dynamic to see like women having
power over men